Who wants cake?
I do, I do!
I hope there is ice cream, don't you?
Birthday parties are really fun.
There are balloons and colorful party hats.
These girls even have tiny umbrellas on their drinks.
Can you hear them singing the Happy Birthday song?
How many balloons can you count?
I count nine balloons.
How do the balloons float like that?
If you guessed helium, you're right!
Helium is lighter than air,...
...so it makes the balloons float when it's inside them.
Can you guess how old this birthday girl is today?
I'll give you a little hint.
Count the number of candles on the cake.
Did you count six?
Great job!
Do you think that she'll blow all of them out with one try?
I do.
I hope that your next birthday party is fun, too.